moteur action à maurepas le septième art
créé des liens entre les habitants
lucky luke mickey vice versa jeunes et
moins jeunes se retrouvent autour des
films d'animation on avait une activité
on devait retrouver les émotions dans le
film vise versa je trouve ça bien que tu
es comme ça
on peut faire des activités n'était pas
à la maison
je jouais le rôle de maurepas en fait
c'était aussi l'occasion de connaître
d'illustrer habitants de la ville pour
cette fête inter générations la
municipalité est satisfaite
l'année dernière nous avions fêté ici
même place riboud les 50 ans de maurepas
dans la ville nouvelle et cet événement
avait rencontré un très grand succès et
on a décidé de reproduire maintenant
cette année d'en faire un événement
récurrent tous les ans à maurepas que
nous avons appelée maurepas en fête est
donc une fête populaire adressé à toutes
les familles rassembler et faire sourire
la mission semble réussie pour la ville
maurepas en fête sera de retour en 2019